nur wenige sprechen darüber was sie
getan haben und wenn dann bloß nicht
erkannt werden frauen in polen die
abgetrieben haben weil der fötus schwer
geschädigt war
die prognosen waren so ich werde diese
schwangerschaft nicht bis zum ende
behalten können oder das kind wird
gleich nach der geburt der auch schwer
geschädigte ungeborene dürfen nicht mehr
abgetrieben werden das gesetz wurde
verschärft
hochrangige kirchenvertreter sind
begeistert frauen gehen entsetzt auf die
straße doch die nationalkonservative
regierung bleibt hart
ein kulturkampf ist entbrannt um die
abtreibung in polen
ich habe gegenwärtig den eindruck dass
wir im mittelalter leben
wir fühlen etwas angst wut verzweiflung
[Musik]
ja
eine polnische dokumentation erzählt die
geschichten das leid von betroffenen
frauen beata hat abgetrieben in den
niederlanden ihr baby im bauch hatte
herz defekte gehirn und nasen knochen
waren zudem nicht voll ausgebildet
mehrere ärzte in polen diagnostizierten
das aber keiner wollte den abbruch
durchführen ich konnte es nicht
akzeptieren in meinem eigenen land holte
mir keiner helfen
ich hatte selbstmordgedanken ich wollte
nicht mehr leben
ich hatte riesige angst was auf mich
zukommt ein zweiter fall auch katharinas
fotos hatte schwerste schäden erzählt
sie im polnischen fernsehen
ich habe gespürt ich werde es nicht
schaffen das leiden meines kindes zu
sehen wenn ich ihm nicht helfen kann
die beerdigung des kindes wäre eine
situation gewesen die ich nicht hätte
ertragen können
ich hatte mehrere schlaflose nächte mit
weinen und entscheidungen treffen wie es
weitergeht schließlich vermittelte ihr
eine frauenorganisation einen termin in
einem polnischen krankenhaus für den
abbruch
doch das war bevor das neue gesetz zur
verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts in
kraft war
jetzt ist abtreibung bei schwerer
schädigungen des fötus verboten legale
abtreibungen waren in polen schon davor
auf einem sehr niedrigen niveau
etwa 1100 pro jahr und davon 98 prozent
wegen der schädigung des fit
in der jetzigen situation nachdem das
urteil des verfassungsgerichts
veröffentlicht wurde ist der weg für
frauen zum schwangerschaftsabbruch
verschlossen
ende oktober 2020 das abtreibungs urteil
des polnischen verfassungsgerichts steht
an
draußen gebete von erzkatholischen
abtreibungsgegner kaya goldeck ist ihr
kopf und sie ist angespannt das
verfassungsgericht seit fünf jahren auf
regierungslinie entscheidet abtreibung
ist nur noch legal im falle von
vergewaltigung oder wenn das leben der
werdenden mutter bedroht ist aber nicht
mehr bei trank empfiehlt vor dem gericht
die zwei welten polens gegner und
befürworter von abtreibung reagieren
prompt auf das urteil
auf beiden seiten hoch emotional das
urteil ist ihr triumph mehrfach waren
kaya goldex ultra-konservative mit einer
verschärfung des abtreibungsrechts
gescheitert jedes mal haben wir gehört
wenn die initiative abgelehnt wurde dass
euer kampf keinen sinn macht geht nach
hause das wird nicht in keinem anderen
land der welt ist so was nie passiert
heute ist polen ein beispiel für europa
und die welt auch frauenrechtlerinnen
sind da und entsetzt polen hatte schon
vor der verschärfung eines der
strengsten abtreibungsrecht europas
jetzt ist das noch restriktiver
patientinnen in solchen situationen
haben selbstmordgedanken und können sich
nicht vorstellen das kind zu gebären
wenn ich einer patientin in der zwölften
woche erzählen dass sie mit einem kind
mit einem tödlichen oder nicht
reparablen defekt schwanger ist wird sie
nun für sieben monate zur folter
verurteilt
lohnt es sich dann das zu besprechen
oder sorge ich dafür dass diese
patientin nichts erfährt und sie diese
tragödie erst nach der geburt erlebt ich
weiß es nicht es ist ein ethisches nicht
nur für die frauen auch für die
betreuenden ärzte macht es die neue
gesetzeslage
wir wenn der arzt schädigungen am fotos
findet und diese nicht behoben werden
können und er der patientin davon
erzählt was sollte die patientin jetzt
tun
schwierig zu sagen dass ich nichts zu
tun kann
ich kann die patienten nur darüber
informieren weil ich offiziell nicht
einmal die möglichkeit habe zu sagen
wohin sie gehen muss ich sage es bleibt
ihnen nur das internet für mich ist
diese situation dieser frauen tragisch
die frauen fragen uns wo sie hilfe
bekommen können wie sie mit der
situation umgehen sollen weil es auf dem
offiziellen weg nicht mehr geht und
jetzt auch die gefahr besteht dass
ärztinnen und ärzte verurteilt werden
für die abtreibung über mehrere wochen
demonstrieren vor allem frauen gegen das
neue gesetz oft bis tief in die nacht
zumeist friedlich und mit masken in
corona zeiten fast alle abtreibungen in
polen fanden bislang wegen missbildung
des ungeborenen statt was nun also
verboten ist
es geht hier ja nicht um wunsch
abtreibungen in diesem fall warum soll
ich einen toten fötus zur welt bringen
ich habe zwei töchter im teenageralter
und ich will dass sie die wahl haben
ich habe ein kleines kind deshalb kann
ich nicht jeden tag kommen aber ich
schicke meinen mann wenn ich keine zeit
habe die polizei anfangs kugel fährt
später einen härteren kurs zivil
polizisten im einsatz
anti-terror-einheiten nur die anbinden
weisen sie ausgebildet für die ganze
hatten um schlagstöcke und tränengas
gegen polnische frauen
eine demonstrantin die zu boden ein mann
sagt er hier hast du augentropfen spürt
sofort das ganze gesicht
doch die frauen lassen sich nicht
einschüchtern von der übermacht der
staatsgewalt dieses bild wurde bis heute
zum symbol eine kleine frau und ziemlich
viele polizisten
die wollen ihre personalien aufnehmen
und verlieren die geduld
der polizist sagt wir möchten sehen mit
wem wir sprechen die frau antwortet
warum cern sehr mir ich habe es schon
gesagt sie aber nein lassen sie mich
einfach los können sie mich loslassen er
dann zappeln sie nicht sie können sie
nicht normal
aus welchem verdammten grund später
nehmen sie die personalien auf und
lassen sie gehen über soziale medien
haben wir sie ausfindig gemacht sofia 29
tier medizinstudentin und gut katholisch
trotzdem fordert sie
entscheidungsfreiheit bei der abtreibung
die kirche soll sich ihrer meinung nach
da raushalten vom polizeieinsatz ist sie
bis jetzt schockiert
ich hatte angst dass er mich irgendwohin
weg bringen das ist die wahrheit
wenn ich mit den polizisten auf die
andere seite gehe sie mich ins auto
packen und man weiß nicht für wie lange
und wo hin was im auto geschieht kann
man nicht beweisen
sofia ist keine aktivistin durch die
verschärfte abtreibung hat für frauen
wie sie das fass zum überlaufen gebracht
viele wachgerüttelt polens staatsspitze
hat die wut der frauen unterschätzt und
die wollen jetzt komplett abrechnen
fordern etwa politisch unabhängige
gerichte als man am anfang sagte die
justizreform wird solche folgen haben
die wir gerade erleben schien mir das
unglaublich ich sagte mir damals nie
unmöglich wir leben doch im 21
jahrhundert
wir leben in einer hölle für frauen seit
jahren eigentlich ab dem moment als das
anti abtreibungsgesetz 1993 eingeführt
wurde und jetzt ist dieser herr noch
riesiger und wir wollen nicht mehr darin
leben polens erzkatholische
kirchenvertreter wiederum sind
begeistert von der neuen gesetzgebung
sie sind eng vernetzt mit der
nationalkonservativen regierung und
einflussreich und wollen seit jahren
abtreibung am liebsten komplett
verbieten ihre reaktion auf die neue
strengere gesetzeslage eine epochale
gesetzesänderung so der vorsitzende der
bischofskonferenz und der krakauer
erzbischof lässt verbreiten
man kann sich kaum eine großartige
nachricht vorstellen der protest macht
auch vor kirchen nicht halt
demos in gottesdiensten liberalere
kirchenvertreter verurteilen das zeigen
aber tatsächlich auch verständnis die
polnische kirche erntet in gewisser
weise das was sie gesagt hat wenn es um
die verbindung zwischen alter und
regierung geht für viele polen ist die
pis die kirche und die kirche die pis
rechtsextreme gruppen haben
zwischenzeitlich sogenannte national
waren zum schutz der kirchen gebildet
legitimiert von der regierung mit einem
erstaunlichen appell wir müssen vor
allem unsere polnischen kirchen
verteidigen
wir müssen sie um jeden preis
ich rufe alle peace mitglieder auf und
alle unsere unterstützer die kirche zu
verteidigen
polens polarisierung zeigt sich auch im
parlament im sale die
oppositionsabgeordnete auf die
barrikaden
ihre wut richtet sich vor allem gegen
ihn jaroslaw kaczynski
das ist krieg rufen sie im typ dem
parteichef und übervater der
nationalkonservativen pis
sicherheitskräfte ziehen auf beiden
seiten spitzt sich die ohnehin schon
scharfe rhetorik bei einer anderen
sitzung skandiert die opposition
richtung kaczynski
du wirst ins gefängnis gehen werden in
polen endlich einen rechtsstaat ist
werden einige von euch einsetzen
polens nationalisten fühlen sich
bestärkt am nationalfeiertag marschieren
sie auf gegen abtreibung für gott ehre
vaterland
feuerwerkskörper fliegen auf balkone mit
protestplakaten und lg wie tief habe
lasst die [ __ ] brennen hört man im
twitter wie die darf eine polnische frau
eine schwangerschaft abbrechen die frage
treibt ganz polen um für eveline
rostowski ist die antwort klar jedes
kind muss geboren werden sie ist mutter
von drei kindern katholikin und
natürlich verheiratet
die wahl ein wort mit dem man heutzutage
um sich wirft ist sehr in mode gekommen
die wahl könnte für mich sein ob ich
mittags pommes frites es oder gekochte
kartoffeln aber ob man bringen der
eigenen kinder als die wahl beschreiben
kann
ich versuche täglich zu leben wie es uns
die heilige schrift liegt laut dem gebot
der kirche aber so wirklich in der tat
lebendig nicht nur in der theorie
evelina hat einen blog zum thema
selbstverwirklichung nachchristlichen
vorbild die demos pro abtreibungsrecht
lehnt sie ab es ist nicht mein
frauenstreik obwohl alle parolen sagen
das ist ein nationaler frauen streik ich
bin definitiv für das leben
menschen wie evelyne werben für die
konservative katholische familie in der
abtreibungsdebatte zeigt sich wie im
brennglas dass polen der zwei welt
dennoch das sind polnische familien
sie haben es satt dass sich
ultrakonservative die deutungshoheit
über familie und patriotismus zu
sprechen
ein sonntagsspaziergang der zum protest
wird für ein liberaleres
abtreibungsrecht für eine bunten offenen
familienbegriff viele regenbogenflagge
wir sind dagegen dass man uns
vorschreibt und eine familie vollständig
oder nicht sein sollte katholisch oder
nicht ob homosexuelle personen in der
familie sein können oder nicht
die polnische dokumentation über frauen
die abgetrieben haben und die frage was
nun wenn der schwangerschaftsabbruch bei
geschädigten fötus nicht mehr möglich
ist
ich plane nicht nochmal schwanger zu
werden weil ich große angst habe und ich
weiß nicht ob ich mich irgendwann dazu
entscheiden werde
die einen verzweifelt die anderen feiern
die abtreibungs verschärfung frenetisch
die debatte über abtreibungen ist ein
weiterer spaltpilz für die polnische
gesellschaft weltbilder prallen
aufeinander
es ist ein erbitterter streit zwischen
liberalen und ultra konservativen
kräften entweder pro oder contra
abtreibung ein in der mitte stehen gibt
es kaum noch
der kulturkampf in polen verschärft sich